good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the second session of today's
conference my name is boo scoopski I'm
from Central Connecticut State
University our session will be devoted
to the foreign policy and its problems
of the Polish Second Republic we have
three speakers who lucky for me need no
introduction will be speaking in
chronological order our first speaker is
a bandage from Yale University emeritus
former Bradford dirty professor of
history now emeritus he will be followed
dealing with the 1930 s by Professor
Mata quarter not from the polish academy
of sciences in warsaw and dealing with
the period of the Second World War
professor Anna chanchala University of
Kansas a merit up I will conclude that
making a few comments and then we'll
throw open the floor for questions so
without further ado I will now introduce
professor Fiat Panda check Thank You mr.
chairman is this working well do you
hear me often I get to the bottom just
feel awful editor close all right thank
you for our Savior I can sympathize with
that ladies and gentlemen the year
nineteen twenty one may be considered as
marking the real beginnings of priests
and foreign policy of the second polish
republic during the preceding three
years Poland's reborn after more than
tree of partitions four-fold frontiers
by arms as well as by diplomacy it
flashed was permanent Rostova kalafina
and wage war against the Bolsheviks by
1921 the situation became stabilized
domestically and externally in March the
parliament adopted a constitution and
Poland signed a treaty of riga which put
an end to the war needs the ground yours
so-called federalist plan of pursuits he
had to be under following three
uprisings in our sadies and the blood
aside a fan of the division of the air
dry replace the border was also drawn
after prevacid in southern east prussia
this completed the work on the
determination of the German border and
unhold intervenes dividing the Duchy of
Chechen kesha produce expectations
however were not fully met the long
eastern frontier was not recognized by
the great powers which men also get some
uncertainty remained about the status of
distant Ganesha and the border with this
way dragony have not renounced
revisionism and so it russia did not
abandoned its final goal of world
revolution place between these two in
D'Amico or late weakened powers Karanka
to search for security what were the
options the advice given up easily to
the pores that they should rely on
Germany against Russia or vice versa was
totally impractical a rapprochement
Berlin was possible only at the price of
border revisions coming closer to soviet
russia sin I'm ricotta
the great powers would isolate program
and nationally and place it at the mercy
of Moscow in case of a German so it warm
program would become a battleground
fully aware of these dangerous worsen
either arise and indeed in 1921 ensign
alliance treaty with France and Romania
and made efforts to come closer to Joe
Slovakia through the Spearmint benefit
attempts were also made to promote a
wider system of cooperation among the
states of in Central Europe yet a purely
defensive or foreign policy with a
strong military component was not
sufficient himself and the new approach
had to be adopted what would it be and
how was such a policy be formulated and
adopted two documents throw some light
on this question in August 1921 foreign
minister constantly spearmint sent his
well-known circular instructions based
on the assumption that problem has
overcome the distrust of his policies
which pervaded the West it was widely
believed there that problem was guilty
of imperialism in the east and was
aggressive reserving other NATO's
Marshall rosovsky was mean unpredictable
it was important to change this negative
image steelman's program stressed
respectful international treaties
corporations
our neighbors and peaceful relations
with Germany and the Soviet Union given
the exposed position of belong to the
threats coming from east and west
stillman wrote that problem needed above
all peace in order to stabilize and
aware of the young state its future
could only be assured by the maintenance
of the existing balance of power based
on the common interests of all the
victor states of World War I the second
document adopted by the council of
ministers in January 1921 had been
prepared by the General Staff an entire
looked foreign policy from the viewpoint
of the security of the state a Polish
historian described it as quote a dogma
of political thinking of the meeting
circles of the 75 according to it the
principal goal of program was to
maintain peace and territorial status
quo it has shown that if fallen was
attacked the Germany also could rely on
friends or without the possibility of an
evolution of French attribute or Berlin
could not be ruled out assistance friend
assistance in case of a Soviet attack
was beamed more problematic hence the
general staff consisted of clarification
of the provisions of the military
convention with fans and recommended the
conclusion of alliances in key Central
Europe there are ideas and principles
where they have elaborated and put on a
front at your honor ball I would not
hesitate to say philosophical foundation
by Alexandra screams arguably the most
important foreign minister of inter walk
around screen stood relative the
country's policy from December 22 to
Maine 23 and from july from before and a
26 well since his talents were not
questioned this is diplomacy was often
subjected to criticism and his complex
personality did not always gain in
France strings to develop these ideas in
numerous features to the same Senate
Foreign Affairs Committee in lectures
given at home and abroad in interviews
articles and finally not finally not in
the center last but if it if you wrote
in much earlier in a book entitled
program paintings whether in or out of
office he exposed his views with a rare
consistency and sought to apply them to
diplomatic valleys screen ski always
placed polish goals and interest in a
wider context he criticizes the
parochialism of his countryman the
national degrees and the inability to
understand how the country was perceived
from abroad he was convinced that one
him to follow understand and analyze the
great international colonies which
program could only oppose it is
unbearable in that it is likely that was
influenced
historical spoon according to which
poland's partitions were loud due to the
fact that Rona fell out of step with the
general evolution of your in his book
screen skin presented a survey of the
19th century system they would work as
important well at first but it carried
the seeds with all instruction World War
one destroyed it and on its ruins arose
the new Europe founded the divinity of
nationality and democracy and marking a
new face to the development of humanity
although waves of ideology did not fully
traveler the paris peace conference in
the sense of assuring peace in Europe if
an endangered it engendered the League
of Nations quote a new holy alliance
concluded for the freedom of Nations a
great moral achievement of the south
egremont and every particular experiment
true screams get out good the league was
a trend younger without means of
enforcement verdicts a conference
without effective power the league could
not prevent war but it could prevent the
victorious end of the world and divide
he notices as an example of despond
screen ski mentioned the popular
reaction during World War bomb which
overthrew three monitors enough all
streets the argued one have to avoid war
having fought himself the world war one
screen see was aboard by the senseless
waste and garbage and he predicted that
unless the policy of enforcing his
brilliant a second even more devastating
war would be inevitable please have to
be found through constant struggle which
demanded the strengthening of the
Galatians rejecting the accusation of
being an impractical idea is Prince keep
it works himself and optimists and the
others as he put it what realis of
tomorrow is nothing else than the
ideology of today before and he quoted
as saying or Machiavelli that it is a
good policy to do today what one will be
forced to the parole what did all this
mean favela screens to declare that the
rebirth of program was not fortuitous
but it was a massive necessary result of
both a logical nature of new engine
predictions the link between Poland and
legal options the Taliban he described a
squat an act of Berlin's rebirth there
was no contradiction between Inge
naturally in the national state and
princely not surprises in the bay calm
down integral nationalists now did he
see the contradiction between the policy
of peace and the maintenance of the
strong army with Bolin's case would not
be a manifestation of military's true
even the routers coach army could not
defeat either of exclusion neighbors but
it could increase the risk they would
incur when attack in this country thus
total foreign policy must rely first on
the league and seven on alliances for
you to consider the fundamental error to
put all trust and alliances and treat
the league as an impediment to the class
since foreign emerged out of the peace
treaties they were naturally the basis
and the starting point of foreign policy
the maintenance and institutional
history is in the spirit of
international solidarity was that he
booted the categorical imperative
foreign policy key defined what as a
synthesis of all basic interests of the
state legal political material more real
and idea and of work it was not a mosaic
of interest litigations what with any
given foreign minister that with as a
fortuitous advocate the task for foreign
policy was to create a great synthesis
of world of thought within the long run
would
laughter is back in a major speech
strings in the clear that he never felt
more in agreement with the gray laws
governing international relations then
when he tried to understand and
reconcile them with the constant
permanent and unchangeable rules of
Polish foreign policy before we look at
the application of these lofty
principles and practice letter from
silver springs is used on the major
European powers or thought he continued
the policies of cooperation and France
have that written forms to Brittany
which he tried to bring closer to
program and they unlike some other 30
diplomats he did not fear a
franco-british offer from of the
contrary he favored it because British
involvement would strengthen the cause
of peace and security in Europe trying
to project an image of diplomacy has
operated and reasonable he was willing
to make minor concessions to Germany for
instance with regard to German national
minority in Poland which bellian use for
for territorial repair leak I'm sorry
for religious purposes a few firmly
defended full of territorial integrity
he was willing to discuss cooperation
even a no aggression really with the
USSR but not at the expense of other
states in his area last but not least he
had a greater importance than many of
his compatriots to the United States
because of that is financial power among
the issues and challenges which shinsky
phase three where of particular
importance published eastern borders the
jeans are proper born and
loka in 1923 French and Belgian troops
entered the room as replace all four
German deficit default or operations
simultaneously that is Wayne E&C spray
para in defiance of the p7 Krinsky
adopted a policy of restrained with a
visa roar affair which were very
dangerous international percussions and
he Traverse right peaceful means to
denounce the defendant me he cleverly
exploited the fact the French either
programmed and emphasized that his
concern was the defense on the
environment of treaties he insisted that
the non-recognition of Dodge eastern
borders for the threat to peace and
stability or those trains the critics
wanted him to be more forceful and
derided his idea is to pronounce man
catching to you over when in april 923
the conference of ambassadors recognized
brody from herbs as established by the
treaty of reader the second challenge
change 1924 when imported to strengthen
the League of Nations British and French
Prime Minister's McDonald and Aereo
launched the so-called geneva protocol
based on arbitration security and
Solomon screen still regarded it as the
optimal solution of the problem of
security and in case in which European
evolution coincided with Roche interest
again you're subject to criticism by the
programming special/john of she coughs
key who argued that only French military
commitments the program would bring
security the powder eventually the
protocol was rejected by a new British
Garnett the fact lesinski never cease to
be pro the third and most serious
challenge came when Germany encouraged
by Brittany proposed a new security
scheme it was to consist of the
western-backed stabilizing drone friend
belgian border with britain has gone
talk as for javanese easter neighbors
the Berlin work on sent only to an
arbitration treaty this created in
dilemma for Paris and also with
maintained the security on the Rhine
have to be accompanied by security on
the viscera public diplomacy have
different options abstain and take a
negative stand aiming of the prevention
of their cords or seek to participate in
the negotiations to say is god as
possible problems interest the first
option carried the risk of making the
French regard the pose an obstacle to a
British guarantee which repair is
desired and the Polish from French
culture alliance as a liability hence
krinsky decided to engage in complex
negotiations trying to propose parallel
security back in the West Indies and
later as an alternative a French and
hopefully brittle guarantee of the
German Polish
triple his effort included even a drone
in the United States perfect leader in
vain for American support aventuras
Tracy was invited to join the powers
meeting in la cama that would
participate only in the drafting of the
german-polish arbitration treat although
she was one of the signatories but that
would perform after fan protocol he had
to be satisfied with obtaining some
concessions a new Franco police radio
guarantee which was saddened okano which
was somewhat equivocal in the provision
of friendly took over its real value
dependent however as one of the Polish
military leaders put it not on the
wording of the text but on the way to
execute domino's denounced in program is
an innocent and since you're sharply
criticized for signing it his policy of
multilateralism was contrasted with the
bilateral approach of course key and
others who believe that the determinant
approach or position would not have
adult France to say oh god defending his
policy strings he believed that he had
achieved all that was possible docomo
diminished somewhat remember the trees
and in just the different reliance the
new conditions it improved the image of
proton noggin Paris as a reasonable
cooperative country and above all it
meant Britain's association
international security again both for
Europe and for product the alternative
would have been complete isolation
target imitation does not prevent the
discussion of subsequent moves that
shinsky named the efforts to obtain for
polar bear
seat of the council of the league a semi
permanent seat was achieved by the
success was arrested and to persuade
Rosco mafia to form Central European
bloc rounded for those remarks
emphasized when you're all of mr. CHP
someone much less appreciate in the
westin he should be but also a Polish
foreign minister operating and rather
happier circumstances and some of the
several colleagues now I'd like to turn
the floor over to the cinematic quarter
not mr. Connally
I will speak about how much monny shee
or bath and polish and bilaterally a lot
has been written about the war polish
foreign policy there are still many
measures which allow the discussion
there what the policy conducted by you
60 and back command to fire was there
any political alternative to this
conception what conclusions can be drawn
from this from this first what part of
the lesson learned by internal prominent
remains some people today the 70
revolution later how did black
understand the position of orange in
Europe it is unquestionable that he
influenced the way Holland was perceived
in that world and as Professor value
observed that personality of back play a
city a
of the West opponent the time at last in
the blood advance of pervious and the
end of the Second World War let us you
this person more from a distance in a
more objective and even way that it has
been possible survive after the feeling
of power in 1926 one of these which he
came to the conclusion that the foreign
policy of Poland should be based on two
columns two fundamental principles
firstly it should maintain the earlier
alliances with flowers and Romania and
secondly it should strive for the
improvement of relations with her both
the neighbors these two assumptions did
not to lost their validity till the end
of the Second Republic of Poland however
policy conducted by al-ghazali st during
his ministerial currency was more
moderate and
one of them days of the back however it
must be observed observed that cholesky
worked in times of peace work
stabilization of Europe with the
locality photo cafeteria today many
historians criticize the Polish policy
tower France after 1934 blame you to ski
and back for weakening this alliance
however polish statesmen were right and
serological was driving is writing for a
sitter independence from france since as
canaries injured rightly observed
apologist absolutely committed has no
legacy in position the since the
o'connor agreements the Holy French
alliance was systematically growing
weaker polish friend emergencies arose
about one from the fact that the
alliance with France was for reports
iguana key in case of war wine for their
branch it was an instrument in the
cocaine for the organization of these
involve a euro u16 and back considered
the agreement with the journals reached
in january 1934 as the greatest
achievement of our diversity you to keep
toward the end of the line managed to
achieve a considerable stabilization of
international situation of following the
declaration of non-aggression 34 and the
non aggression drinking reunion computed
in July 32 was created to the basis of
Polish foreign policy in 30s the similar
has read the relation of German Foreign
Relations after hitler came to power
open to new possibilities before
palatability the lazy germany
international delighted in the
antagonistic I olives is allowed fallen
to conduct a policy independent vote in
belen both of Berlin and Bosco original
declaration of non-aggression repellent
some essential of firmly to the benefits
among them
security and the improvement of it
relations in the international arena
Poland gains a possibility to conduct a
more independent policy both top of the
Western powers and stability of more
effective policy in Central Europe
Eastern Europe it has also reached
itself of its ally lateral dependence on
the trench arrived in Germany Poland
lost its validation of a seasonal state
it has according to unpublished
propaganda environment science
possibilities opened to
he's turnin the position of college in
central Eastern Europe try to be
used by publish leadership fallen a
cheap at the postponement of the German
territorial clients but was not able to
avoid the weakening of the alliance with
France although Poland's wire coming to
terms with the Third Reich never
intended to drop if I as the press if
the integration became available under
the circumstances of health years in
january 34 agreement of germany
determined it rewards of interest in the
various projects of collective security
and negotiations of the Mr Okada since
the whole government value to more than
bilateral agreement with German the
multilateral ones the fact
of conducting an independent policy the
rice Collins best dishwasher was not
negligible beautiful skin but at the
same time no system of collective
security Lula was imagine imaginable in
above the participation of moment the
government accepted that is agreement
with the Germans would weren t its
equivalent security answer on the other
hand for Hitler Hitler the normalization
of relations with problems was only the
point of departure to his burrow the
glass heater wanted to involve tolerance
in their common fight against every
Russia while Poland wanted to conduct an
independent ones well Chancellor so
Hollinger as an important element of the
system of the Alliance's fair right he
planning to tolerate the Polish policy
of Palace only for a certain time just
the declaration of January
for only a provisional arrangement
involved the change without a chance for
survival one can deny that peaceful
relations between Poland and Germany
were an essential quality of the
preservation of equilibrium in
central Eastern Europe polish leadership
attached great importance to maintain
good relations with Germany however it
was it was only the nomination of how in
German relation the protective power
from the catastrophe of German solid
foundation it must be added that the
Soviet leaders were always open to deal
with Germany against Poland in this time
but the Philip was not impressed such a
combination the general climate of
Poland relationship either Germany which
try to include Poland in the orbit of
its influence was better than the polish
them in the Polish solid relations the
later however usually normalized were
more and more submerged to a cold war in
the end of her thirties until the spring
of 1929 however Poland fit men
principles of balance and didn't not let
to incur any obligation if they made us
that muj directed against the other the
possibility I don't sorry the policy of
balance that back tried to conduct was
not his own idea as it is sometimes
wrongly laying in his or her just was
the conception of mother do 60 which was
that which was the logical consequence
of the varieties of Polish history and
the political geography in Eastern
Europe it was impossible to make an
agreement with Germany in Russia of
interesa and Poland would achieve
nothing by such a policy it also should
be edit the no serious polish polynesian
did for marriage conception of an
alliance of Germany or reproach and on
cooperation with solid Russia the
balancing of international agreements
non-ideological understanding of foreign
policy and attachments to cabin and
diplomacy were the main ideas of you can
pack the Bellator ilysm preferred by
back included not so much resistance
and multilateral agreements above all
the immersion part Amalia so
characteristic in the galaxy of her
Gia's vote using scale back up their
dogs had to be conducted with existing
German and Soviet government regardless
of its internal internal policy they
catch this metal learning his methods
and on our Idol conception of foreign
policy you Sookie and back to revert the
metal of concrete and besides bilateral
agreements to the religious principles
of collective security we diluted the
actual obligations they combined these
connections with a distance and critical
attitude of nations which layer eyes was
enacted a text policy tower
Czechoslovakia and the ultimatum about
the an indication of territory beyond
the alsa river
that the acceptable 1938 is considered
to be the great error of this policy
indeed this move contributed to the
creation of a very good climate around
fallen in Europe there was an impression
that Poland moves the Polish mustard
parents in Czechoslovakia were
coordinated River Germany we should have
ever see here the arguments of one of
the architects of Polish foreign policy
of this time which was published on the
father for London ever trudging who
being by the means one affects men are
very loyal and so critical of him the he
said I'm sitting I had an impression
that we were a blind alley we simply
attacked the chance demanded equality
equality of rights to publish my
knowledge change roger weil really
created a situation where we could
either admit that we have suffered a
complete disease or we could ask Hitler
to give us a part of for any are for
this reason I will have already relieved
by the Polish argument
gotcha information liberation as
promised from the awkward situation
whether that going can't and with hands
with the Germans we found ourselves
empty-handed while they took everything
this feeling of course didn't undermine
my addiction that's logical people newly
was our defeat while in the annexation
of the territory beyond the old arena
was a desperate attempt to get out of
this situation finish of the the end of
the nation the policy of appeasement
conducted by the Western powers placed
Poland in a very difficult situation the
establishment of the quartet of the
great powers as an organism to carry out
the change of waters in Europe left to
the marginalization of Poland
international banana and turned it into
an object in the relations between those
hours therefore X attitude to the
Western powers in the second half of 30s
was marked by a principle of limited
trust this was fully realized by the
British and the other two also Howard
can we march 1939 one of this reports
to unpack that back bassist policy of
the connection that my brother British
of the French government would be
prepared in case of each to effort to
offer effective assistance to problems I
hope to resist the power expansive moves
of Germany in Central Europe together
with the Munich conference autumn 1938
all the previous reasons for conducting
her policy for us this was the end of
the very rare a stabilization achieved
in east-central europe on which various
combinations and actions mahady would be
forecast of march 1934 saying that the
colonel sake of collect relations with
Germany and Russia who survived no more
than four years came through this is a
view in historiography thats why the
matter is it be understood
validation of the ovulation report
neighboring others s transitory back to
list that this provisional stage will be
a natural will be a natural a turn into
a permanent arrangement this is the
alternation of studies of her co-author
of a book about the post-journal
relations in fact this is true but
nevertheless this was a matter of
secondary importance in my opinion in
actually in the conditions of the
growing changes it represent mr. Beckham
never corrected to responsive or
maintain good
the journals as long as it is good
during on silent with the innocence of
principle of reserve independence of
college we have to emphasize it again
the approach man where Germany was
possible only to ass international point
this point which comment would not sure
a little beyond was being the pendants
and territorial integrity of the Polish
stage therefore they didn't hesitate to
reject either the demands for the for
the return of the VCG of thanks to the
German to determine right and bought the
territorial at highway no driver
railroad across Omaha marana the
acceptance of G's demands would probably
an important to avoid the scenario which
foreign experience in 1939 but this
would mean the problem would become a
bottom of Germany the grain of the
leader of the third life were
unacceptable not because they would
undermine the president of poland as
sons Islam has content but their
rejection was not caused by the pressure
of polisher public opinion but resulted
components from home base and polish
leadership spill conviction that they
could not be reconciled the most eager
interest of all that what decided the
type of orange
nineteen thirty-nine was another
horrible part in a Polish leadership
didn't perceive danger of British offer
a very much everyone although it seemed
to be real as Indians through the world
history of pre-war Europe it is well
known of the nation of August
twenty-eighth well in which neither back
described Poland situation was as not
too bad why did a very much tolerance
position so mistaken i think that in the
first place what's the terminated in the
Polish foreign ministry what the
connection that the one who is would
term any polish German Catholic
which was made a Soviet Union retain its
not neutrality and the first in the best
stage of European war but didn't expect
so the Russian attack oven element was
convinced about Russia's that will I
will record the observations of
neurology team won again these
observations are in his report to back
from August 24 disagreement protects the
Soviet regime and a disagreement with a
top bottom part is a grungy of that less
felonies to them whether in any case of
international conference or a localized
war on the other hand in the case of
total war which apartment Poland's would
involve its Western Allies the Soviet
would be interested in retaining their
neutrality and it is an American
unimaginable that would want to help the
Germans the anticipation it seems said
that that was a similar opinion as
Masada planned besides our kinky
rightly suppose that the soviet russia
was trying with the concept of laminin
firms to take control of over
territories which final signature of
negotiations in solid 1939 kita ceded to
the Soviet Union while our IMG's
measures let us remember that the
Western powers in the first place the
government of France and the United
States did not involve the police
pathologist of the content of the secret
to the event the water park although
current will use of easter vast region
in the face of the event of a lot of
action no polish foreign policy could
say Jane dependence of the stage or even
partly modify the scenario established
in Moscow and battling the scenario the
decision of the region of Europe into
the serious of ether of ultimate
arrancars Beck scheme was left with no
beautiful man ever unless we see
capitulation as an eternity in a line of
the eternal knowledge it is beyond any
question that even
is the left-hand known of the secret
qualities of the Sahara non-aggression
pact has never even at very limited to
you tomorrow no of this would change the
way of the inevitable partition of
forged stage after 20 / of August
undulating parts of the news of her it
was an Alison only the western parts
could modify their course they took
industry in 1939 opponent has no other
possibility this should be record again
the basic assumption of polish
leadership was the conviction that there
was no possibility of a permanent
improvement of relations people burning
water at the same time a condition
remaining water that study would not
appear as an ally of the right in the
face of an al-qaeda information
including Poland and the rest of Palace
which would be affected in its minute
operations such chances were created by
the Holy British alliance concluded
officially on 25 08 / tonight which put
the German right in the face of an event
or allergy of an eventualities of war on
two fronts but this was a possibility
that general asks of the earth countries
especially France it not know how to
take adventure how to take adventure
adventure of course also knew nothing of
the top secret revolutions of the
journalist task of translating a field
that nine which says that the case of
the heat poland would be restored to
call it would be restored after the
uterus act of european war and the
result of polished and time is of
secondary importance the polish
leadership was against that a clear
position of great britain as it was
assessed in that time a sugar so far to
the radius of fans start being the
operation in the West it is true that we
need the back / sleep at all full of the
mass and was realistic in this love
opinion of
significance of Poland's our affairs
however experience shorter that England
has visited saying in the different
defense of the path of power in Europe
although it would not have been
effective allowing horses and disposal
at the first stage award of the
continent one translate in the advance
of the top coat to the 30 years of peace
was precisely the support of London now
after Poland's after Poland receive the
differences later transformed into a
fight after Aaron alliance a situation
and international situation underwent
essential change the music director was
justified in loading down that road to
Paris the leads to another and what is
more in the summer 39 he came to the
condition that probably does
successfully reached the end of this day
the quadrant but this was not enough to
avoid the defeat it is still very
difficult to form an object opinion of
the back and his position in the
if your opponent is to aways rely when
that fostered political biography it is
quite understandable and not so not fair
that in post-war Overland people's
college there was a tendency to present
him in the most negative large as
possible the results of Polish policy
between
1934 and 1913 iowa city remained to be
the subject historical disputes of many
other years to come myalgia hosted
historian of polish german relations
wrote that ninety germany who knew your
character whose video character was not
clear to back however we must write in
Europe of the end of generous there was
no conscious of the real character of
Nelson and native German not only to
back these questions were imported to
resolve giveness policy was only
interested in the first place by the
leaders of Western palace has their
policy of appeasement and also the son
and holy boobage a cotton last with a
remote that I'm seeking that was simply
write in trying to maintain the line of
public policy in a difficult balance
between the corners of our meter and
west
neighbors perhaps is even not so much
light as presented there with no options
while my only regret that he endowed is
solicitude for his food independence of
action with the trace of a fortune
gesture his mistake however didn't
relate to the essence of our foreign
policy but its presentation to our
partners he approached the tasks he
faced with great intelligence of all so
in a sense of my god rocks and with
self-confidence the surpassed his
experience it anand had no authority to
the policy it conducted in her pious she
could not rely a design on a close
cooperation with the rapidly weakening
class which was undergoing an internal
crisis on the Africans collective
security was not possible although many
empty prices have been said on the
subject for this reason that we were in
criticizing the tactics applied way back
certainly she was not the model of
diplomas to developed you coming
but there was no opportunity to this
principle orientation because this
orientation was a policy of balance the
political accomplishment of use effect
must be critically assess however this
assessment must correspond with the
social social moral hsieh of the error
you wish in the race as was right people
served by chemical shit people the
secret is problem of diplomacy the
otherwise any attachment of any
historical personage will be non
historical and we should not forget the
versatility that not every lost cause is
that since not always a good cause maid
service thank you thank you very much
mr. Kotter nut well with that
essentially positive reading of mr.
Beck's foreign policy we move from the
problematical 1920s through the
lugubrious 1930 s but these are not
going to get worse because we now turn
to the Second World War and dementia gel
ok now the foreign policy of the Polish
government-in-exile is what I'm going to
talk about it is generally considered to
be part of the Second Republic there was
a continuity of government as I'm sure
some of you may know under the 1935
Constitution the president of poland had
the right to nominate his successor and
he did so much its key in romania first
nominated a peon llamado Guiche offski
who was rejected by the french
government he then nominated what is
forex give each as president of poland
and then a general shakal ski for this
web Schakowsky became prime minister and
also commander-in-chief a little later
and the first Polish government-in-exile
was it France and yeah we can keep that
up there and then in London after the
collapse of France now as you may know
the Germans and the soviets attacked
poland and the Germans on the first of
September and the Soviets on the
seventeenth and this was in this was the
consequence of the secret protocol to
the German Soviet non-aggression pact of
august twenty-third would you show the
next one the grinning people in the
kremlin office Ribbentrop and stalin
shaking hands i think or about to and
shahbaz nick off the head of the soviets
of general staff in the middle and this
was on august twenty-third and this is
when they agreed on the first line first
Ribbentrop Molotov line which is
generally forgotten which you show us
the next one was shown a demarcation
line or what is this oh yes this is a
David Lough cartoon in England
which is rather brother explicit I think
Stalin and Hitler greeting each other
later on David lobe became rather
anti-polish but at this point
sympathized with Poland okay now the
next thing is to show you the first
demarcation line no no not that one I'm
sorry that's just the text i forgot to
take his out it's a Pravda should be
Pravda of September 23rd right yes of
course it didn't refer to the secret
protocol which was secret and was denied
by all Soviet governments until april i
think or 1989 december 1989 i think it
was finally acknowledged and even
condemned by the Supreme Soviet which
was the first freely-elected one this
says a demarcation line between German
and Soviet armies in Poland you see it
goes right down the middle through
Warsaw along the Vistula narf and sun
pisa river was added later and then
there was another second one a treaty
which established the frontier but
September 28 in Moscow and this is known
as the Ribbentrop part of line and here
pravda shows it as the frontier between
German and Soviet state interests well
what was the main problem the main task
of the Polish government it was to
restore the state of Poland as an
independent Poland within its pre-war
frontiers however with possible at first
possible and then later suddenly
demanded acquisitions of German
territory you could show the next
transparency which shows Poland the
Curzon line which was the
main problem in relations see this is
the Polish one I think that's Davis
Davis ah when after Germany attacked the
Soviet Union on jun 22nd the Soviet
Union automatically became an ally of
the anti-german coalition and very
quickly made it quite clear that they
wanted as a price of their engagement in
the war in their part of the war to keep
the territories they had gained in 1939
and Stalin was clever enough to modify
this demand to say what we want is
simply the Curzon line with a few
modifications but before I come to that
yeah I think I ought to mention the
Polish Soviet agreement to restore
relations which was signed in London by
General Schakowsky on the one hand and
Soviet ambassador even my ski on the
other and this restored relations which
obviously had been broken in 1939 by the
Soviet attack on Poland before this was
signed the Soviet demand was an ethnic
Poland which really meant the Poland up
to the book and Vistula and son line
which had been traced in 1939 but um
shakur ski managed with the help of
Anthony Eden Foreign Secretary of
Britain to provide a compromise formula
and in the agreement of July thirtieth
known as the shakaar scheme I ski packed
the Soviet government said it recognized
the turret
arrangements in 1939 has no longer valid
as no longer valid so it didn't come out
and say we recognize the pre-war
frontier but we recognize that our
partition of Poland with Germany is no
longer valid now that wasn't enough for
some ministers three ministers of the
Polish government resigned ah I would
like to show the transparency of Poland
as it was in 39 41 I think that's done
no that's the one after that I'm sorry
so that you would have no that's an F
okay okay that's fine one of the
arguments in favor of the Soviet demand
for an ethnic Poland which was dropped
in in 39 41 but we survived later was
the ethnic composition of eastern Poland
this is a map which is obviously not
very detailed but it does show you that
the poles were a minority in eastern
Poland overall although they had
regional majorities which are marked in
in dark colors obviously if
self-determination had been really
followed in the interwar period you
would have had some kind of deal of
Russian and Ukrainian states may be
autonomous but political circumstances
did not allow for that there was a lot
of discrimination against the other
Russians and Ukrainians in Poland that's
quite true but you must also bear in
mind that things were far worse for them
in the USSR 7 to 10 million Ukrainians
perished in the man-made famine Stalin
used to break resistance to
collectivization 7 to 10 million people
Ukrainians and then of course
the Russians so in a comparative sense
yes there was discrimination against
ukrainians and Bill the Russians but it
was a matter of death for millions of
them in the Soviet Union so that has to
be borne in mind but the the argument
which you often come across even today
is that after all Soviet security
demanded that it keep its 1941 frontiers
I was an argument very often made it was
even made by of course by so we
propaganda and by British and American
writers that Russia had been invaded
twice in the 20th century 1914 when it
was actually in Poland attacked by the
Germans and austro-hungarian but the
famous curves online which you do see
here goes back to roughly 1920 although
it had been proposed earlier in 1919 as
a demarcation line between polish and
Russian administration's now in July
1920 when Red Army was coming up to
Warsaw there was a Polish delegation at
Spa in Belgium where the French and
British and think Italians maybe were
meeting to discuss German reparations
and an armistice line was worked out the
Armistice line was called the curtain
line after Lord Nathaniel Carson who was
a British Foreign Secretary of the time
little bit nothing to do with it because
he his experience was as Viceroy of
India it was based mainly on the on the
Russian frontier eastern frontier of
Russia
poland 1914 but then it was extended
into what was then called East kaliesha
Marple scoffs Kanye West Ukraine and the
calls were tricked there because the
Polish delegation signed an armistice
line in his Galicia along the existing
front line which was far west of the
curse of mine so someone in the British
Foreign Office made that line the
farther west line the curse of mine and
what is also not very often known is
that the Soviet government actually
rejected for charisma and said we have
to we want to negotiate with the poles
and what they meant of course negotiate
while advancing on walsim and then in of
course the roads were defeated which is
another thing that is often simply not
mentioned in our textbooks university
textbooks and recent discovery in Poland
was that at that time polish
cryptographers had broken the radar mean
ciphers and so kasinski knew exactly
where the Soviet Union the Soviet units
where which helped him a great deal
although we still taking the risk making
a counter-offensive in the middle of
August against them and also polish
cryptographers could get on the same
wavelength as the two kucharski orders
to his red army units and they were
blocking these orders by reading the
first word of the New Testament Bible
again and again and again so that
doesn't detract from Butte skis genius
and some polish journalists have
contended but anyhow the curse of mine
was the line that was very much i would
say favored by the british government in
1939 in the Alliance that was signed on
August
the fifth there was no guarantee of
Polish frontiers but of independence
there was a guarantee of help against
the Germans and any other alien nations
but not the Soviet Union because the
British were always thinking of how can
we get Stalin over to our side and the
bargaining counter was eastern Poland
from the very beginning which is an idea
that the poles of course did not share
now going back to the Sikorsky my ski
fact this was a began a period of really
fairly good relations between the Soviet
authorities are released Alan and the
Polish government in London a Polish
army was raised in the Soviet Union from
many prisoners of war different figures
are given four hundred thousand three
hundred thousand may be taken by the Red
Army in September 39 a lot of these
rank-and-file were let go home
practically immediately but probably
about ten thousand officers maybe six
and a half thousand police and various
other people were taken to the Soviet
Union to three special camps as you know
in Kosciusko star cook and stir abuse
and their location became known when
they began to write to their families
they were allowed to write from the end
of November early December 1939 to the
end of March 1940 so the Polish
government knew that they existed these
people all these people then suddenly
all contact broke off and so when the
Polish army was being formed in the USSR
the Polish authorities kept on asking
where are these people where are these
people and we have all kinds of
documents on that and the Soviet answer
was always they were all released in one
one instance when Stalin was speaking to
Shakur ski in December 1941 when she
course key was in Moscow as was Germans
were in the suburbs of Moscow by that
time and they were not thrown back to
the seventh eighth of December by Zhukov
so she course key was taking a big risk
but in that conversation which we have
polish and Russian records she course
key again asked where are these offices
and Stalin said as far as I know they
have all been released that maybe some
of them escaped to Manchuria that was
black humor where where is terrible scan
estas go fan and cozy us can Manchuria
the other entom so what happened of
course you know is that the Germans
discovered the cat in graves this was
absolutely this one site we didn't know
about the others until nineteen ninety
and the German army was near Smolensk in
western Russia and discovered and
Gerber's decided to make it a big
propaganda issue to try and split the
Allies the Polish government had to do
something most of the army that had
gotten out of Russia with General Anders
in 1942 went to the Middle East and then
fought in Italy they came from these
territories so it was outraged and it
was clear to anybody from the evidence
that these were people who were
massacred in 1914 before the German
soviet war so that the Germans couldn't
have done it and yet the Soviet
government said it's the Germans polish
government did what was possible it
turned to the International Red Cross
committee in Geneva
and said would you please conduct an
investigation but the trouble was that
the International Red Cross couldn't do
it without the acceptance the agreement
of both parties Germans and Soviets
Soviets refused and started a propaganda
campaign against Poland that it was
collaborating with the Germans it was a
traitor and all that and so wild
pressure from the British ally on Poland
to think about the post-war frontier
without eastern Poland was there before
Catton it increased tremendously after
that Winston Churchill and the British
used to call him good old Winnie tried
very hard to re-establish polish Soviet
relations but he said the condition is
you must agree to give up eastern Poland
and the Polish government could not see
its way to do that and I'll explain why
in a minute the United States stood on
the Atlantic Charter which some of I'm
sure most of you have heard of was a
kind of program war aim signed by
Roosevelt and Churchill in August 1941
on board the battleship I think it was
off Newfoundland somewhere and among
other things it said that they did not
support territorial aggression and they
would not countenance territorial
changes during the war and any changes
without consulting the population now
this is something that the pose believed
in implicitly however President
Roosevelt who had been very effusive to
shakur ski and in support of Poland's
pre-war frontiers when Schakowsky first
visited the united states in 94
one in mid three Wizards actually began
to back away from this and privately he
was already thought the talking in 1942
that Stalin might have Soviets might
have eastern Poland the Baltic States
and Bessarabia this was done this was a
noted by Adolph burly an assistant
secretary of state and it's in his
memoirs navigating the rapids around
after Stalingrad victory early februari
43 Roosevelt very clearly came over but
still privately because he didn't want
to lose the Polish American vote to the
idea that eastern Poland must go to
Russia and then you have the first
Quebec conference which is codenamed
quadrant August 17 to 24 1943 and for me
that is the turning point because the
military and political leaders and
Churchill and Roosevelt were there
decided that Eastern Europe was to be
the Soviet war theater no Western troops
in Eastern Europe and from then on
Eastern Europe was seen as in the sphere
of Soviet influence or Soviet sphere of
influence and so what was Churchill to
do if he chose a strategy of Tara Mendes
pressured Sikorsky and then ran
Schakowsky was killed in July 43 of
Gibraltar on Mikolajczyk who was the
prime minister after him come to an
agreement come to an agreement during
the wall before the Russians get into
Poland and the Polish government kept on
saying we can't do this without
consulting for the poles and polish
majority opinion was completely against
giving up eastern Poland you can see
this in any number of of declarations
I'm trying to find these well I'll have
to do them from memory you know that app
Tehran big three meeting at tehran
november 28 december 243 churchill
trotted out his proposal to stalin to
move poland west like a soldier taking
three steps left close and he
Illustrated it with matches in case
stalin didn't understand was telling you
that very well he had proposed that to
eden in december for you mom but The
Jerusalem say Roosevelt said to stall
him that he favored moving Poland West
didn't say anything about the curtain
liner obviously was involved and as for
the Baltic States he also understood
that they would have to be in the Soviet
Union but he would like to have some
sort of referendum for the sake of
American public opinion and Stalin said
he understood but there'd be no
international observers and Roosevelt
explain you know I can't come out in
favor of what Churchill said because i
have this presidential election coming
up next year in november 44 stalin
understood now did the Polish government
know about all this well he did and it
didn't when Churchill came back from
Tehran he did talk to Michael I chick he
didn't say this is what we decided at
tehran but he said this is what i think
is the best solution for you to agree to
give up eastern Poland and in return you
will get territories from Germany in the
north and in the west without
specification but it meant East Prussia
and part of pre-war Germany and ecologic
said well we can't really do this but we
have to consult the country well
what did the Council of national unity
rather had national Adobe which was the
underground sort of parliament of Poland
very small political leaders the
delegate of the Polish government who
was the head there he said her brief the
council agreed to the proposed western
boundaries in the removal of the Germans
but it objected strongly to any
discussion with the Soviets regarding
the revision of the eastern boundaries
and he said and I quote no one in Poland
would understand why Poland is to pay
the Soviets the costs of war with her
territories and independence so and this
was polish opinion in Poland and abroad
and not only the people who were in the
car near craiova and other organizations
political organizations on the ground
and in the political parties in the West
the Communists of Poland didn't want to
come out for this the head of the pepper
Air Force kabalyero would DJ Communist
Party of Poland which didn't call itself
communist kamukha wrote to gr g Dimitrov
who was the former secretary-general of
the former Comintern which was dissolved
officially in May of 43 but carried on
as a department in the Central Committee
of communist party of the soviet union
go look around this the main problem for
us which prevents us from creating a
popular fronted Poland or a broad
political front is a question of
frontiers and he said if st. Anthony's
Brotherhood came out in favor of
revising the eastern frontier it would
immediately be denounced as a Soviet
front organization receiving Soviet
money to get the Polish nation under the
root of Stalin so even if a Catholic
organization had come out in favor of
revision it would have been denounced so
that english translation comes from the
beginnings of communist rule in poland
edited by Anthony Polanski and melissa
drew Kier came out in London 1980 I had
first read it in a happy lead asea
dissertation in in warsaw in 79 and also
thought it was quite remarkable and then
on mikolajczyk was pretty much forced to
go to Moscow you know at the end of July
of 1944 while he was on his way there in
Cairo from louisville KY wrote Tehran
Moscow he heard about the proclamation
of the Polsky committed visible in
general de Vega the Polish committee of
national liberation was formed in Moscow
july twenty second i think became the
national holiday bill and he continued
and tried to come to some understanding
this town and also told him that would
be an uprising in war so any day and
Stalin said oh yeah so was Molotov
Molotov said we're about eight
kilometers from war so this was I think
on august first or second and then on
august 30 saw Stalin and Stalin said yes
well we expect to take war so soon but
and we will help for the Warsaw Uprising
would have been giving up eastern Poland
and recognizing the Polish committee of
national liberation is the at least the
core if not the polish government polish
opinion wouldn't do that even in the
midst of the fighting in Warsaw when the
polished leadership of the army and the
civilian
situation was told about a compromise
proposal by the Polish government in
London that after the war Poland should
retain its chief cultural centers in the
east and the absolutely necessary
sources Nash natural resources which
meant keeping Vilna of illness capital
of Lithuania now was preponderantly
polish them and wolf in the southeast
which was preponderantly polish before
the war poles were absolutely wedded to
keeping at least feel nominal wolf and
the oil fields as the natural which are
in the in the live off region so when
bore Komarovsky and the delegator the
Polish government received this Polish
government in London proposal compromise
we will agree to give up most of eastern
Poland not so many words except for
Vienna and hoof in the oil fields
although the frontiers will be fixed
after the war the reaction was this is a
complete surrender and the polls have
not fought the Germans for five years
for the sake of an eventual surrender to
Russia so very briefly and I know I've
gone over my time a little bit no polish
government could accept these conditions
in wartime without committing political
suicide and then we don't know what
would have happened if it had we
probably a complete breakdown of the
resistance movement why go on resisting
the Germans if this is what's going to
happen to ourselves to the world now you
know that ecologic resigned finally came
to the conclusion in after a second trip
to Moscow and
and getting failing to get the Polish
government to agree to some sort of
session of eastern Poland he decided
that nevermind we have to make an
agreement with the Russians and he
believed that his party the peasant
party the largest party in Poland would
win free elections and these free
elections were guaranteed in the altar
agreements februari 11 1945 which also
said that the Polish eastern border
would be the curse in line and in the
West that would be acquisition of
territory so well as you know there were
no free elections the one thing that
Poland did get out of the war was the
frontier in the West and we don't have a
no we don't need any more of these which
was a temporary frontier must have east
part of East Germany went to Poland and
East Prussia and this temporary frontier
lasted till October 1991 it was
officially recognized the unification of
Germany but in conclusion I would like
to suggest that we do bear in mind that
the polish government several
reconstructed government to Tony shall
degrom major poll majority opinion
simply would not agree to give up
eastern Poland and this they didn't
agree to most of them until after the
Russian army got in and obviously you
couldn't do anything about it so
historians writing about this who
condemn the polls as a romantic TSA's
unrealistic as living in cloud cuckoo
land and all that they have to remember
this was a democratic government which
listened to its public opinion as for
Roosevelt I'm sorry to say he stated to
ambassador Harriman in may of nineteen
forty four according to harriman papers
I don't care if the neighboring states
neighboring on
are communists I don't care his main
goal was to keep the Russians in the war
win the war in Europe and then have
Soviet aid against Japan otherwise
Americans would lose two million manner
would take an awfully long time so in
this sense Churchill was trying hard to
actually to keep some sort of balance in
Europe he wanted the American troops to
stay where they were in Germany instead
of retiring to their occupation zones as
degree dat yata ah he was all he got
actually was a independent Greece but no
polish government could have bowed to
this and the British Americans
especially Americans considered eastern
Poland and the Baltic States Embassy
Arabia Northeast Romania as expendable
and why because they did not consider
their vital interests were engaged in
Central and southeastern Europe and so
as one of the Polish newspapers
underground papers wrote in March 44
after Churchill's speech at Parliament
in which he proposed the session of
eastern Poland in return for German
territory they said we don't want the
Russian Munich and so it was impossible
i would say for any polish government
during the war to accept this thang
thank you very much professor kincheloe
for allowing me to demonstrate my
technical virtuosity in in running those
running those slides I'll make my
remarks extremely shorts we have some
time for questions and the first thing
that strikes me is in any consideration
of the foreign policy of the Second
Republic a foreign policy which ends
with the invasion of the country by its
two neighbors the destruction of the
state and the occupation of the entire
national territory can hardly be
adjudged to success as a consequence of
that one is forced to consider what are
the problems that inhibited polish
foreign policy in the 20 years preceding
the invasion and it seems a tripartite
division might be in order and that is
when analyzing the successes and
failures of the foreign policy of the
Second Republic to what degree can we
attribute those successes and failures
first of all to what we might call
structural features in the international
system the Preferences predilections of
the major powers and their
interrelationships the second is to what
degree can we attribute the successes
and failures to intrinsic polish
limitations demographic economic
military and to what degree can we
attribute them to the specific failings
of individual makers of Polish foreign
policy and so the one question I would
ask all of our three panelists to
consider is how they would apportion the
blame for the fact that at at the end in
1939 Poland found itself the founders
foreign policy in ruins are what I'll do
is I'll ask that one large question
rather than the several smaller ones I
have in mind only in the interest of
time and ask in chronological order of
those who spoke to respond to that
question and once they have the floor if
they would like to respond to the points
raised by their colleagues speeches they
may do that as well after having given
each of our three presenters therefore
an opportunity to speak I'll then throw
open the floor to questions and follow
the
suggestions of mr. Snyder earlier with
each question or identify himself before
asking a question and please make sure
it is a question restaurant well I think
that is quite a legitimate question to
say well polish foreign policy did not
prevent they collapse an item that nine
partition of the country fourth
obviously we have to start with the
statement that into or Poland was not a
great power but as a French historian do
as man put it very well it wasn't
translating mentally from French it has
been a sight their mother pull up along
the Ronettes come and made that in
eighty thousand reasons making bleep ass
reconciliate at straight they'll come on
daytime failure it was the programs in
his fortune that it was not be born as a
great power and was could not reconcile
itself to the position of a small state
in a sense this plus the fact that poll
done placed between two great neighbors
which were in Lima go from the beginning
could not condemn it the foreign policy
on its own which could have hurt the
catastrophe so I think that in a sense
if we look at it from a perk historical
perspective the Polish foreign policy in
the interwar period is that of
attempting to square a circle there was
no possibility acting on its own to
achieve the position which would have
prevented a German Soviet rapprochement
against bowknot is the true decided so
the diplomacy as I put it did not have
any aces it could play with small cards
and the question is how well well
cards played personally I feel that in
the case of the twenties and this was
considered some extent the early
thirties the reliance was on the
concepts a collective security league of
nations and hopes that in the
franco-british rival ray which in a
sense was one of the great misfortunes
because the League of Nations relied on
these two powers the League of Nations
as a diplomat put it was not it it was
they once France and Britain pursuit
different policies and each of them
tried to associate dominate to its
policies obviously the League of Nations
could not succeed nonetheless I don't
see what else poland could have done in
the twenties except to try to reinforce
the League of Nations reinforce security
in the thirties again i think that the
change which puresox kid express so well
i think is being of the two cannons and
then at the conference for the leaders
of his party in 1934 when he said that
obviously we cannot guarantee agreement
with germany for more than four years
and i think that this is in a sense the
key the polish german aggression
declaration is a key to the Polish
foreign policy and authorities was it a
major achievement was it a mistake
obviously it had to be paid for which I
don't think the port fully realized by
weakening of the relation France in a
sense and I think general tso's
skipper advanced trying to understand
what was the real purpose of the
non-aggressive attack was to single also
wanted to signal if he thought sir to
Paris that the pores could make an
arrangement with driving under all
therefore they were not a burden to
France they could wear a partner with
whom France had to record this I think
was a mistaken opinion they nonetheless
the pact did delay the confrontation
Germany the famous remark attributed one
of the poorest statesmen as own eyes
remarks is probably apocryphal that
German publish agreement relegated from
the program from the German menu from
the order to the desired and many things
can happen between these two things so
that's in playing for time as for the
Second World War I think that only
chance I would fall at had theoretically
the party government which again was a
poor relative which again was not a full
partner of Britain and America or Russia
the only chance was to persuade britain
and the united states that Soviet
control of Central Europe was a danger
to that but this is this was in the
conditions of the Second World War a
pretty hopeless position and it only
made Poland repressive made for not
appear in the eyes of the British
Americans as the country which has not
forgotten anything which has not learned
anything who does not want to accept
your realities other than that the game
I see so in a sense my point of view
commenting on these three papers is a
very pessimistic one the fate of Poland
lessons was preordained and obviously
one can add a number of reasons a number
of elements which made it more difficult
personality problems especially of back
the public opinion in Poland which do
not always operate in a way which would
assist the foreign minister in carrying
out his duties conveying wrong or a
negative image of code and abroad etc so
one can agree with all of that but still
I don't think that the essence would not
have been changed whatever data thank
you very much professor coronado chapter
I think that the most important
mr. Beck 1939 was the internalization of
a publisher he turned College crossing
international arena and I think this was
the massing of what what may be done
this situation and polish Polish Gaddafi
has no similarities to gain real animal
Western palace and the seclusion of the
obligations of western parts follow as I
mentioned in my statement pouch policy
has never been able to present to
prevent the cooperation of
Germany however we can respectively
consider the possibility of cooperation
with Germany on the basis of learning
purposes from October 19
38 if not be reminded here that a German
government proposed to the return of vc
g of x equal to germany answer to
construct a territorial highway across
the polish so-called coach going on we
have the documents that i wish i were a
ministry it does
the considered different possibilities
of abstraction such a highway but
without the cosmic territoriality
without the factory tow yard and the
demands of key that were simple and
wantage necessarily the XL variety and
in fata calculation
the acceptance of German proposals was
for event impossible we should policy
couldn't avoid the situation with was
son of 1939 and what impossible to do
not more than was the dynamic I mean
after internalization of published
question we must remember that polish
question was nineteen thirty-nine
connected with the general question of
peace sells me that negative or and
mineral a dune it was the maximum
maximum of what bad actions thank you
very much mr. to talk well I don't think
I have any prob professor damage said I
would simply like just to add what I
said that I gave at the top is very
general I have a lot more detail which I
couldn't possibly
maybe this will be published made enough
but I would like to underline the fact
that although Poland today is in the
best situation who has been 400 years of
war there are still circles in the
United States which feel that the most
important and say so the most important
thing for the United States is to have
good relations with Russia aside from
Iraq with the problem President Bush did
apologize for the altar agreements which
is very nice of him if he tied it to the
Middle East and fifth democracy sort of
there which I think was probably
important for him and then of course he
would have to explain to a very
complicated why he was going to Moscow
in his big military parade and after
whiskey and putting rogue around input
maybe they had some water as well but
there is a danger we're not out of the
woods a little still between Germany and
Russia you notice the other Russia and
Ukraine and thank goodness for the
Ukraine and I hope it manages to stay
independent in spite of the tremendous
economic pressure by Russia for
political means oil and gas supplies to
Ukraine but there is a worrisome thing
to me and I'm sure other people and
there is this gas line from the morgue I
think along the bottom of the Baltic Sea
to Germany and that is far more
expensive to build an overland Poland
and Lithuania is definitely political
it's probably an exaggeration call it a
new German second act renew German
Russian practice not to publish to the
Russian commentator wrote in the Congo
sons after the news came on but it is
worrisome his words and suddenly and
interest to try and reduce our
dependence on oil and gas by the
developed economies thank you oh yeah
well because apparently professional
life so why is he creating such an
important experience and also regarding
could be proved I keep this one then the
second question is maybe disadvantage
regarding
ocean I like you to speculate my main
ask you about what happened in Poland
and John the collective
and Russia in 13 i will give us any
chance okay component of my question it
would be bad your United States and
British recognize the important than
Europe that was the only chance for us
and I won't be first of all whether Jane
they would recognize fair today and the
second is where you'll agree that the
Cold War mini origin originated from
that is american-made the why was
curtains name is Oscar simply because he
was the Foreign Secretary of net decided
any company you know it's not always it
was prepared by British diplomats
advisers etc who are with him and spa
and we just signed it agreed with it but
as I mentioned the cursor minor in
history she differed from the line that
the Polish delegation have agreed to
which was the front line at the time
West which was eastham sorry waste or so
load cousin was simply foreign minister
design
the proposal and that's all I can tell
you I'm sure he didn't disagree with no
experience thank you have a bandage what
was great fun well since we have her it
is the time then we take refuge in a
saying or professor Vera shitski which I
rather like he wrote that historians
have had enough time to explain what
happened not to bother about what did
not have yes sir message from second to
Parvati who has two holes of leaders of
photographer for the family to both of
21 center so I forget to present myself
here through the cross from
rather not very visible what my song
here graduate of political science yet
this message is to be very under to buy
buy buy contemporary polls this lesson
suited year sometime revolution and
political change is in Europe bomb in
nineteen ninety-one to a cognitive music
way but this vessel is our policy of
reconciliation with German our policy to
be a member of europe united Europe via
member of European million to in dogma
of our foreign policy never equation I
like to say a bit more in a member of
relieving group of European Union thank
you well thank you might cut it back
would you speak louder because I have
problems with caring to the professors
in shower that the question of Carson
vine is very well described in the
second volume of Professor Ian CA which
book which was the taller than the
British Ireland volunteer British
Parliament yourself in there he
describes there in the Annex the
professor manin oestrogen I believe was
the name of who robbed that an appendix
today to them volumes about the mistake
that was seen has done at the British
diplomatic offices about the line and
that it was proposed to be corrected but
because of the sandwich by the an
ambassador conference of ambassadors
happen of about the same time it wasn't
recruited with nothing
yes whether that was an article written
by a sweater cause for our coffee on the
courage man to get were published
journals and Senators it went what year
was just before yeah that was a very
good exposition of the to thank you
brief questions yes sir to my knowledge
stop it they executed not 10,000 but
more than 20,000 in college officers
this world operation you I'm sorry
you're not right except is great
amusement College polishes really nice
they were shocked on the spot we don't
have a good records about the college
policeman this is one point the second
point there iron curtain was drawn in
yoga the third point kamukha came to
power 10 or 15 years after 45 so in 45
he didn't play any rock there was built
asuka Morosky genere scheme then I was
still on the bottom he came 50 years
later and formula for the interest of
time Jordin I got you working hard and I
you become the center of the polish
please no dialogue of the audience yes I
would like I would like just to answer a
couple of your points the total number
was well over 20,000 I know they were
not all
just finished editing an
english-language volume with cutting
which will come out in Yale University
Press according to Soviet figures in
February 1940 there were eight and a
half thousand officers if you would
distribute these according to NKVD
records in February 1940 there were
eight and a half thousand polish
officers in the three caps mainly
incautious mr. August over 5,000 of them
were reserved offices according to the
same NKVD figures in February will march
1940 the stache golf camp at 6,500
prisoners of code five thousands of
ordinary policemen so I do know that and
I as I said while you were talking to
this gentleman he will find all this in
the volume english-language volume of
cat in documents which I have just
edited will come out in yale university
press next year NOS toca Boca he was in
1944 he was the leader of the pepper air
in Poland and so he represented his
opinion and
time I forget what the third photos
thank you very much our terminus signal
me that our time is up i like to thank
our speakers and you ladies and
gentleman the audience thank
you